right uh this is from d-n-y-u-z
it says this is a story about the rise
in
vasectomies
uh among men now i shouldn't really have
to clarify that it's vasectomies among
men because who else are going to get
them but you know how it is these days
uh it says in march mike pridgeon a 28
year old comedian based in new jersey
got a vasectomy and posted the process
on tick tock his doctor off camera can
be heard saying little pinch here and mr
prision winces his eyes shut tight
behind his glasses bracing for pain
vasectomy a quick outpatient surgical
procedure that cuts the tubes that carry
sperm is one of the most reliable and
cost-effective forms of contraception
available with almost none of the side
effects of complications of birth
control methods that are geared towards
women yet it has remained relatively
rare in the united states an estimated
500 000 men get the procedure each year
some surveys suggest roughly five to six
percent of men between 18 and 45 have
gotten the procedure as opposed to
roughly 20
of women aged uh
15 to 49 who have gotten their tubes
tied
but that might be starting to change and
interviews with the new york times 10
urologists across the united states said
they've seen a notable uptick in
bookings for the procedure this summer
especially among younger child-free men
whose resolve to not reproduce appears
to have sharpened in the face of a
precarious economy worsening climate
change and a more restrictive family
planning landscape the weekend after the
supreme court decision in june to
overturn roe v wade google reported that
searches for a vasectomy and our
vasectomy's reversible surged it's still
unclear whether the increased interest
in vasectomies is a blip or the
beginning of a long-term trend that
could foster greater acceptance of the
procedure then it goes on to give more
evidence that this is this is indeed a
longer-term trend and more and more men
are deciding to neuter themselves
uh willingly
now the most concerning thing about this
is the rise
especially in child quote unquote child
free men getting this procedure
and the first thing that's concerning is
just the term child free
which of course by design makes children
sound like some sort of disease
you say child free
like you might say cancer free
and and this is done on purpose
because
people that are quote child free they
don't like to be called
childless because if you say childless
it makes it sound like they're missing
something
and they don't want that so they'd
rather they'd rather they would rather
make children sound like cancer
than make their own situation sound less
pleasant to themselves
and so that's why there's been this
campaign among the childless to to say
no don't call us childless we're child
free
we're free of it we're free of the
burden
well let me ask you something what if
there was someone out there who kept the
log of every single thing you did every
minute of the day i think that'd be
pretty creepy well what if i told you
that's exactly what happens every time
you go online your net your internet
provider like at t or comcast is allowed
to store logs of every website you've
ever visited and they can legally sell
this data to anyone they want that's why
i always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you're doing online now many of you if
you're more perceptive you might be
wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn then doesn't the vpn
get to log and see all my data and
you're right to think that way many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy but have
been caught logging customer activity
anyway expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.comwall show right now and
find out how you can get three months
free the other issue here is that you're
also
uh
for for for people who are
choosing
to sterilize themselves essentially
before they've even had kids
you're giving up on something that
you don't really understand and and this
is the paradox that you you can't really
understand parenthood until you've
experienced it
and the reason for that is that it's
it's transformational
right it's one of those
and there aren't there aren't many
things like this in life
but having kids is one of them it's a
transformational moment
where you actually do transform it
becomes someone different than who you
were before
uh
you know once you become a father then
you're a father you're just a simply a
different sort of person than you were
before you were a father
that's why i you know i like to say that
in the in the act of conception in many
ways it's not just
one life that comes into being but it's
really sort of three lives
you have the child that that is
conceived
but then you have the mother and the
father who are also sort of born in this
moment as well
that's why i know and i know this is the
case for a lot of parents when i
i look at my uh entire life
before i got married and had kids
and i look at all that and i didn't have
kids until i was 25.
but i look at my whole life before that
as my childhood right up until i was 25
and hardly even my own childhood it
feels like someone else's life entirely
sometimes
that's how foreign it is to me now
that's how much i've changed that's how
different my life is now
from the transformational effect
of um
[Music]
you know accepting the responsibility to
be a parent
of embracing this vocation
so along with all the other problems
with people willingly sterilizing
themselves and choosing not to reproduce
and essentially giving up on human
civilization the process one of them is
that you are again giving up on
something that you you don't really know
what you're giving up you can't
understand you can't understand what
you're missing what you're losing
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast